there are aspects of this film that fans
are not ready for there were aspects of
spider-man no way home that even the
cast weren't ready for as it happened
there were secret dance parties insanely
long improvs terrifying three-person
jump stunts and for some reason a whole
lot of loot we've got all the making of
details coming at you right now
making movie magic no matter what need
someone to get pinned upside down in a
harness holland is the man for the job
leaping effortlessly through cars no
problem
holland did not get off easy with the
stunts for this one but of course they
were worth it for these results it is
easily the most impressive
fight scene i've ever seen in a
superhero movie i'm i was blown away by
it watch out world zendaya is ready to
direct she was on set a lot to shoot her
scenes but even in her downtime she
couldn't pull herself away from the
action i spent a lot of time on set just
watching because i'm very interested in
directing and our fingers are crossed
very tight hoping zendaya's most recent
love story movie idea actually gets made
you do have to scream when you fall the
iconic mj falling moment what we
wouldn't have given to seen that in real
life
it looks a lot cooler in the movie than
it felt in real life yes
oh well maybe not every time i would do
it as myself i would just kind of
fall even as an awkward falling bug
zendaya nails it friends that jump
together stay together
okay so this might just be one of the
most intense tests of trust there is i
tell you what was really fun was when me
you and jacob had to jump off of that
scaffold that was fun together and we
were all like attached to each other
good thing this trio has each other's
backs in every way
hey we need more lube on set
sorry what why exactly well what do you
have to say tom that's why we have
bottles of blue yes because it says
zippers right
that's great for the zips and all but
for the people who needed hand sanitizer
it got a bit weird so he walks over and
he's chatting to me and he's like hey
man can i get some of that hand
sanitizer what was the actor meant to do
so i'm squeezing all this stuff on him
i'm squeezing it squeezing it squeezing
it and he walks off and you can see him
on set like this goddamn hand sanitizer
then it got worse
the same thing happened with the boom op
so he's doing a scene and i can see him
like this he's like i can't hold on to
the boom it's just slipping everywhere
we're all pals here right with all those
long days on set things are bound to get
a bit awkward at times i farted on
unfortunately yeah it's tough the suit's
tight the harness squeezes i felt the
rattle evidently not a deal breaker good
thing these two are so close
it may have been a couple of decades but
willem dafoe is still a force to be
reckoned with in the marvel world tom
holland might not have known exactly
what he was getting into working with
the green goblin legend there's this one
scene where he has a speech it's
probably what two pages worth of
dialogue every single time it was
different and we must have done it 50
times but spoiler alert he did and the
movie is all the better for it how many
balls of yarn do we think zendaya has on
her rider i was like what am i going to
get everybody for christmas i was like
i'll just make them some scarves that's
what i'm doing all day that's right the
set of spider-man was also the home of
zendaya's new hobby knitting and you
used to come to set to watch quite a lot
and find the goblin and i turn around
and you'd just be there nipping sorry is
spider-man in need of new shoes
after dislocating his ankle in the last
film marvel made sure a special boot
with solid ankle support was ready for
his costume this time around but it came
with its own complications
but to get my feet in i have to wear
plastic bags over my feet to slip in
welcome to filmmaking in 2021 alfred
molina instead of the puppeteer handled
tentacles he donned in spider-man 2 he
was flying solo on set only to have
those tentacles added afterward but the
cgi didn't stop there
just a teensy bit of cgi de-aging
happened to make him look more like the
dock he played all those years ago
number eleven
without those puppet arms molina needed
a way to suavely move like dr ock and
marvel had the solution they had this
rig called a toothpick rig which is like
a long bar with a platform and then it's
weighted on the other side it was super
cool and all but the actor not being
able to control where he was going was a
definite downfall so now we're chatting
and then all of a sudden he would just
kind of disappear
it's pretty easy for benedict
cumberbatch to not let any spoilers slip
before the film officially premiered the
actor didn't even read ahead in the
script and never watched a pre-screening
because i'm excited to see it
okay so that's pretty much the sweetest
answer there ever was number 13.
i always have this fear that if he's
like working really hard or something's
happening that if he had to like throw
up per se he did nearly waterboard
himself filming a particularly sweaty
scene in homecoming so zendaya has a
right to be concerned she's right
someone should get on that zendaya might
get her mouth washed out with soap in
addition to knitting zendaya also took
up learning some very special skills
thanks to boyfriend tom holland the
magic of english curse words i do this
thing when i'm around him for a while
where
i speak
with british inflections but not the
british accent we can't say zendaya's
skills aren't varied
is this a vampire movie
why so many cloaks
oh the power of disguise and marvel
knows how to do it well they would walk
around set with these cloaks on and he
took his hood off and i almost like got
really scared i was like oh [ __ ]
how many hollands appeared in this movie
tom holland got to have pretty much the
best time filming spider-man with not
only his girlfriend by his side but his
little brother as well who did some
filming with the team while his scene
ended up being cut from the movie it's
still made for a very special memory on
set who wouldn't want to work with their
girlfriend especially if it's zendaya
holland's real-life relationships with
his co-stars make this work a total
dream it's incredibly special to do it
amongst people that you care about and
you loved sharing the screen with
incredible actors and people is bound to
be a win
she's one of the most incredible people
i've ever met and and and i love it a
bit siri can we get some rihanna going
were you there for the dance party i
wasn't there for the dance party jamie
foxx knew how to make this set a party
even without peter and mj around neither
of us were there and jamie was
definitely having dance parties whether
we were invited or not i don't know they
danced they laughed they made an epic
action movie not a bad gig everyone was
working hard but being able to dance and
really enjoy doing the production is
what it's all about where have you been
all
also known as the uncomfortable second
skin
it seems like our boy tom has a kind of
love-hate relationship with the suit on
the one hand
that suit is is uh it's pretty
incredible to wear and it's so realistic
that sometimes it feels like it should
actually work but then again
the suit is not the most comfortable
thing in the world but it looks
fantastic spider beauty is pain boo
what's really crazy is just how many
different suits there have been
different styles and of course the many
copies needed just to get through
filming we'd think holland would have
wanted a little bit of a break but he
wasn't under contract so adrenaline
junkie that he is tom holland went all
out as soon as i finished i went
snowboarding and i have an amazing photo
of me facetiming you with blood all over
my face an intense way to celebrate but
hey who can blame him how else do you
celebrate a movie this big luckily his
longer break will give him plenty of
time to recover from any other
rebellious injuries he might be getting
fingers crossed he doesn't go too wild
it's never a dull moment on the marvel
set and especially not in spiderman no
way home which was your favorite behind
the scenes moment